Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Meta-Ebene wird 20 Jahre alt in diesem Jahr. Das muss ich mal feiern.
Machst ne Militärparade.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 526 vom 16. Juni 2025.
And I already feel so old.
Also wie viel fehlt dir noch zu den 45 Millionen, die so eine Militärparade kostet?
Welche Währung?
Dollar.
Tja, also mindestens.
Mindestens 5-6 Tweets von Donald Trump.
Mindestens 44 Millionen. Fast 45.
45,9.
Mir fehlt auch das passende Militär. Man könnte ja so eine Podcast-Parade machen.
Wir können ja die Einhorn-Stadt. Wir haben ja die Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Einhorn-Standarte.
Die könnte man mal auflaufen lassen. Aber November ist scheiße.
November ist das?
Ja, doof, oder? Müssen wir uns was anderes einfallen lassen. Ja.
Wenige 10.000 Leute und es war irgendwie vorbereitet für Hunderttausende,
aber irgendwie, ich hatte auf irgendeinem Social Network auch so,
ein Thread von jemandem gesehen, der da erstmal so ein paar Kilometer an den
leeren Tribünen vorbeigegangen ist, dann irgendwie noch so extra fail,
die noch nicht mal die VIP-Tribüne war voll,
also die haben irgendwie den Fehler gemacht, ihre VIP-Tribüne nicht zu überbuchen,
sodass sie am Ende selbst da, wo die Bilder gemacht werden sollten,
keiner saß.
Das ist so traurig. Oh Mann, ey.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wenn hier eine Militärparade wäre, müsste ich...
Ja, naja, also ich meine, es sah genauso traurig aus zu seiner Inauguration,
von daher macht es keinen großen Unterschied.
Ja, genau, das war dann auch noch irgendwie von Coinbase gesponsert und von UFC.
Und ich glaube, die haben sogar Sponsorendurchsagen gemacht.
Ich habe wirklich nicht viel Zeit darauf verwendet, mir dieses Spektakel zu geben.
Aber also einfach diese Militärparade diese Militärparade.
Als würde man hier den Zapfenstreich irgendwie.
Dieser Zapfenstreich wird Ihnen präsentiert von hoffentlich Allianz oder irgendwas,
Bestattungssitz ja was wäre denn so das Äquivalent von Ja okay,
äquivalent von Coinbase wäre das gleiche. Bei uns wäre es dann so die Sparkasse.
Diese Militärparade wird inspiriert von Sparkasse.
Kreisparkasse Hannover.
Übrigens, wer auch jetzt Werbung haben wird, ist WhatsApp.
Da haben sie gedacht, da haben sie gedacht, dass das irgendwie verpasst wird,
dass die Leute das Facebook vergisst, dass sie da deine,
Sozialbedürfnisse gefangen genommen haben und irgendwann hat wahrscheinlich
einer bei Facebook gesagt so, warum machen wir eigentlich keine Werbung bei
WhatsApp und dann hat wahrscheinlich irgendjemand gesagt, wie,
wir machen keine Werbung bei WhatsApp. Seid ihr bescheuert?
Natürlich machen wir sofort Werbung bei WhatsApp. Was?
Und jetzt kannst du demnächst bei WhatsApp, bei deinem Messenger,
ja, also nicht mehr nur dein Selbstdarstellungsbedürfnis,
auf Facebook, sondern auch so wirklich persönliche Kommunikation und Austausch.
Kriegst du jetzt Werbung reingeballert?
Das ist einfach so ein Krebs, dieses ganze Werbungsding.
Aber ich meine, Womit hat denn WhatsApp versucht, Geld zu verdienen bisher?
Muss man tatsächlich sagen ...
Also nicht in dem Ausmaß, wie es Facebook in der Akquisition Geld gekostet hat
und das ist ja bei dieser ganzen Kartelldiskussion auch genau das Thema,
dass Facebook quasi so mächtig und marktdominant war, dass sie diese Konkurrenz
kaufen konnten, ohne sie so überhaupt monetarisieren zu wollen.
Das ist ja in diesem ganzen Verfahren über Zerschlagung oder Diskussionen darüber,
die ja auch weiter stattfinden, wir hatten glaube ich vor ein,
zwei Sendungen darüber gesprochen,
dass das eben nicht eingestellt wird von der Trump-Regierung,
weil der Zuckerberg einfach nicht tief genug reingekrochen ist.
Und da wird natürlich genau das auch diskutiert, dass sie diese Akquisition
gemacht haben, Facebook diesen Laden gekauft hat für, was waren das? 45 Milliarden oder was?
Ich glaube WhatsApp war damals relativ günstig. Ich habe es nicht mehr ganz 20?
War das nicht sogar nur 3 oder 4 Milliarden?
Achso, nur.
Naja.
21 Milliarden.
21 Milliarden, okay.
Oder 19 Milliarden, das ist jetzt, okay, hin und her, also ich gucke hier gerade
so eine Google-AI-Zusammenfassung, da stehen ja tausend Zahlen,
aber ja ungefähr 20 Milliarden.
16 Milliarden initiales Gebot, 21,8 Milliarden finaler Preis, ähm.
Also, davon waren natürlich das meiste Aktien und in Cash waren es irgendwie vier.
Ja, die Aktien sind aber trotzdem weg.
Ja, ja, sag mal, es ist nicht so, dass da jetzt irgendwie nur Geldbündel von A nach B geflossen sind.
Aber es ist natürlich eine Menge Holz und ob sie das reinbekommen haben,
keine Ahnung. Ich meine, am Ende hat es ja Ihnen vor allem erstmal einen Mitbewerber
sozusagen vom Hals geschafft.
Das ist ja primär der Wert dieser Akquisition gewesen, weil es einfach sehr.
Schnell… Genau deswegen wird es jetzt auch behandelt im Kartellverfahren.
Ja, richtig so. Und mit Instagram ist es eigentlich genauso gewesen.
Ja. Und jetzt ballern sie da auch bald Werbung rein. Sie hatten ja auch,
das waren ja auch diskutiert, dass sie diese Kommunikationsplattformen,
also Facebook Messenger, Instagram, Direct Messages und WhatsApp irgendwie merchen wollten.
Das war nämlich die eine Milliarde, die ich gerade im Kopf hatte.
Instagram war verhältnismäßig billig.
Ja, ein Schnäppchen eigentlich.
Das war ein Schnopper. Also für eine Milliarde, rückblickend,
hätte ich machen sollen.
Gleichzeitig hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht die Möglichkeiten gehabt,
aus Instagram dann das zu machen, was Facebook daraus gemacht hat.
Ich würde sagen, die Betriebskosten sind da inzwischen sehr viel höher.
Und Google hat YouTube für 1,65 Milliarden US-Dollar damals gekauft und ich
weiß noch, wie alle so um mich herum so, was wollen die?
Werbung machen.
15, wie lange ist das her? Das ist noch länger her, das ist ja schon fast 20 Jahre her.
Ja, aber WhatsApp war so das eine Ding, wo sich noch nicht bewahrheitet hatte,
wenn du nicht bezahlst, bist du das Produkt.
Da war WhatsApp noch so ein bisschen, brauchte man noch einen zweiten Satz für,
nämlich diese ganze, das hat Facebook nur gekauft, um zu verhindern,
dass aus den Leuten was wird.
Naja, ist jetzt eben auch zu ändern. Also WhatsApp bald mit Werbung. Viel Spaß mit eurem.
Ich hoffe, die machen das nicht kaputt. WhatsApp. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Wieso? Hast du noch irgendeine Kindergartengruppe, die du überwachen?
Wo die Eltern... Also WhatsApp kann als allererstes gehen.
Also WhatsApp ist halt einer der Großsponsoren und wichtigsten Developmentkräfte
für das Erlangen-Ökosystem.
Okay. Gut, kann also weg.
Ich bitte dich, ganz wichtig.
Das wird ja auch nicht weggehen. Aber gut, Werbung, ich weiß nicht,
ob sie die Popularität ihres Chatdienstes damit nennenswert erhöhen.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ich glaube, da kommt die erste Werbung und dann fragen die Leute,
Herr Marlinus, was ist nochmal mit dieses Signal? Kann ich denn nochmal geigen?
Oder die sagen halt machen halt auch irgendeinen Pay-or-Okay machen das mit
Werbung so kaputt dass du sagst komm ich gebe euch drei Dollar im Monat.
Ja und in gewisser Hinsicht weiß ich ja auch gar nicht wäre das das schlechteste eigentlich,
Also ich meine...
Nein, natürlich nicht. Der Nachteil wäre, dass man dann Facebook Geld gibt.
Ja, okay, gut. Aber wenn man so einen Dienst halt auch benutzt,
dann ist es ja auch okay, dass man dafür bezahlt, wenn das so einen Wert hat für einen.
Ja, das kann man aber, dann nimmt man auch einen, der wirklich einen Wert hat.
Also dann zahlt man halt für Signal oder...
Für viele Leute hat WhatsApp ja einen Wert.
Ja, denken die. Jedenfalls, Facebook kann ja eh keinen einzigen Schritt machen,
ohne dass Max Schrems sagt, hehehehe.
So, hehehehe.
Und er hat natürlich sofort gesagt, naja, das ist ja genau das Gegenteil von
dem, was das EU-Recht vorschreibt.
Ohne freiwillige Einwilligung ist die Verknüpfung der Daten und personalisierte
Werbung ganz klar illegal. Geht natürlich anders.
Und deswegen machen wir euch das kaputt.
Das wird geschrämst. Das wird geschrämst.
Und jetzt machen wir mal Feedback erstmal, wa? Ja, genau.
Christian schreibt uns zur Diskussion rund um die Einreise und Visa in den USA.
Zum Thema. Hier werden zwei Sachen von euch vermischt.
Die Einreise mittels ESTA, touristische Einreise ohne Visum,
ist auch weiterhin möglich.
Immerhin reisen auf diesem Weg jährlich etwa zwei Millionen Deutsche ein,
auch wenn die Zahlen zuletzt um 30 Prozent eingebrochen sind. Nur, muss man sagen.
Und ja, weiterhin soll man dort seine Social Media Accounts angeben.
Was passiert da eigentlich, wenn man das nicht tut?
Ist egal. Ich bin gespannt, was vermischt wird.
Ich hatte gehofft, ich hätte ausreichend
klar gemacht, dass Esther und ein Studentenvisum was anderes sind.
Aber ich glaube, Esther kann es auch, glaube ich, nur drei Monate im Land bleiben.
Nicht zu Businesszwecken, sondern oder zumindest nicht dort irgendeine,
also zu Businesszwecken ja, aber nicht dort arbeiten oder so oder eine Uni besuchen.
Aber das wird uns jetzt gleich erklärt.
Er führt aus. Was jetzt verstärkt kontrolliert werden soll, ist die Einreise
via Visum der Kategorien F, M und J.
Dies betrifft neben sämtlichen internationalen Studenten auch den von Linus
angesprochenen Schüleraustausch.
Bei diesen Visa sollen jetzt die Social-Media-Aktivitäten der Einreisewilligen überprüft werden.
Dies wurde Ende Mai verkündet und Marco Rubio, der US-amerikanische Außenminister,
hat alle Konsulate weltweit angewiesen, keine neuen Interviewtermine für die
Visa-Vergabe zu vergeben, bis dieser Prozess neu organisiert ist.
Seitdem hat man, Stand 10. Juni, nichts mehr Neues gehört und alle Studenten
und Austauschschüler, die im Herbst in die USA wollen und die noch kein Visum
beantragt haben, wissen aktuell nicht, wie es weitergeht und wann neue Interviewtermine
zur Visa-Vergabe erteilt werden.
Es darf davon ausgegangen werden, dass es sich hier um eine Retourkutsche auf
den Erfolglosen, weil wenige Tage zuvor gerichtlich untersagten Versuch handelt,
der Universität Harvard den Zugang zu diesem Visa-Vergabesystem zu entziehen.
Eine ziemlich unverhältnismäßige Retourkutsche, weil es ja nicht nur Harvard
trifft, sondern sämtliche Unis, Highschools, alle Au-Pairs und so weiter und so weiter.
Auch abseits von Linus' Hinweis wird es also aktuell für austauschwillige Schüler
nicht so ganz einfach in die USA zu gelangen.
Okay, gute,
Erläuterung,
Glück gehabt eigentlich für alle, die jetzt irgendwie in die USA wollten,
dass das Leben das verhindert.
Ja, muss doch was anderes sagen. Es gibt auch noch andere interessante Länder.
Nicht alles, was schief geht, ist schlecht.
Weiterhin gibt es Feedback zu unseren Ausführungen der Bundeswehr-Cloud,
den sogenannten R-GAP-Clouds, also dass die Bundeswehr dort mit Google-Technik
sich ihre eigene Cloud zusammenbauen lassen möchte.
Hier schreibt Jujanus bezüglich der R-GAP-Cloud-Technologie.
Vor anderthalb Jahren konnte ich mit dem Germany-Lead von Google Cloud über
On-Premise-Clouds reden.
Also On-Premise, wenn das sozusagen auf dem eigenen Gelände stattfindet.
Damals war dies schon ein Riesenthema bei allen Providern, als klar wurde,
dass die EU Cloud-Soveranity pushen würde.
Mittlerweile arbeite ich bei einem anderen Cloud-Konkurrenten.
Zu denken, dass nur weil Cloud-Provider ergabt sind, eine deutsche Bundeswehr
vor Trumps irrationalem Verhalten sicher wäre, ist vielleicht naiv, aber ganz sicher dumm.
Solche großen Cloud-Provider sind die brennenden Hütten der This-is-fine-Memes.
Sie sind derartig komplex und bloated, dass sie ununterbrochen gewartet und
repariert werden müssen.
Ohne Support gebe ich solchen Clouds maximal ein paar Monate Laufzeit,
bevor zentrale Services aufhören zu funktionieren.
Und es ist fast unmöglich, IT-Kräfte schnell in die Wartung einzuarbeiten,
da das Know-how zum Betrieb dieser Systeme extern gelagert ist.
Immerhin reichen sie zur Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme, Damit ich Fehler zum Beispiel
auf einer Ergap-Cloud der US-Regierung debatten kann, muss ein armer US-Soldat
einen kompletten Traceback händisch abtippen und mir zuschicken.
Das halte ich ja für einen ganz wertvollen Hinweis.
Ich hatte ja gesagt, okay, dann bauen die sich das hin, Hauptsache ergibt und
dann ist es aber ihre eigene Geschichte.
Da habe ich jetzt relativ wenig Einblick, wenn ich seinen Kommentar richtig
lese und deute, dann ist auch das, was Google Cloud da abwirft, nicht das Järbe von Ei.
Und man muss halt auch sagen, und das stimmt natürlich, Unabhängigkeit,
Erlangt man dadurch, dass man eben auch die Technologie von Grund auf beherrscht,
im eigenen Haus aufbaut, lehrt,
vorantreibt, dort sein Know-how auch ausbaut und eben jederzeit auch für die
eigenen Bedürfnisse verändern kann.
Und das ist natürlich dann in so einer Situation unter Umständen schwierig.
Das ist glaube ich sehr wichtiges Input,
Ju sagt ja auch er arbeitet mittlerweile bei genau einem Konkurrenten davon,
ohne den zu benennen kennt diese Technologie also sehr gut,
aber das was du sagst ist natürlich absolut richtig wenn du unabhängig sein
möchtest dann nimmst du natürlich,
mindestens wenn es schon jemand anders gebastelt hat dann nimmst du wenigstens
Open Source dass du weißt, du wirst hier nicht,
in die Abhängigkeit gezerrt,
und idealerweise natürlich, dass du die Kompetenz für Weiterentwicklungen und
so weiter in irgendeiner Weise sicherstellen und auch heranzüchten kannst und
dich da nicht in eine Abhängigkeit begibst.
Und sorgst auch dafür, dass zum Beispiel die Technologien, auf die du dann aufsetzt,
auch wenn sie Open Source sind, gegebenenfalls von so einem Sovereign Tech Fund
auch supported werden aus der EU oder aus Deutschland heraus.
Genau, so versuchst du irgendwie Flugzeuge selber zu bauen, also dieser gesamte
Souveränitätsgedanke, den das Militär pflegt, zeigt sich ja auch darin,
dass Europa dann versucht seine eigenen Kampfflugzeuge zu bauen,
um nicht in die Abhängigkeit zu geraten.
Oder dass Europa die ganzen Mobilfunknetze von Chinesen bauen lässt und sich
nachher ärgert, dass man in die Abhängigkeit geraten ist.
Oder die Meta-Ebene sich die Podcast nicht von Spotify ausliefern lässt,
sondern halt irgendwie eigene Infrastruktur aufrechterhält.
Ja.
Ihr könnt mir gar nichts.
Und dafür auf ungefähr die Hälfte der Hörerin verzichten.
Hauptsache souverän.
Aber sehr, sehr gut, dass wir da jetzt dann Google Cloud haben.
Das wird uns weiterbringen.
Und wenn ich die Geschichte mal weiter erzählen darf, jetzt baut man sich den
Kram dahin, dann hat man so ein nicht maintainbares System, aber merken wird
man es trotzdem erst, wenn man zu abhängig davon ist.
Und dann wird man entweder für die nächste Hälfte von den 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
wieder aus der AirGap Google Cloud weg migrieren auf irgendwas, was funktioniert.
Oder es ewig darin lassen und dann hat man eben souverän verkackt.
Souverän verkackt, ja.
Okay, ja, dann danke dafür. Dann haben wir außerdem noch ein kleines,
einen kleinen Nachklapp.
Ich glaube, das habe ich in der letzten Sendung nicht erwähnt.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass die Bundesregierung ja sehr selektiv jetzt auch beginnt, Urteile,
selber auszulegen, gerichterliche Urteile selber auszulegen oder zu ignorieren,
spezifisch, weil das Berliner Verwaltungsgericht in einer Eilentscheidung festgestellt hatte,
dafür musste das Berliner Verwaltungsgericht vermutlich auch gar nicht so lange blättern,
dass die Zurückweisung von Asylsuchenden auf deutschem Gebiet rechtswidrig ist.
Das machen Gerichte ja so, die denken sich ja nicht irgendwie was aus,
sondern die versuchen, die Gesetze zu lesen,
die die Legislative beschlossen hat und zu sagen, was steht da drin.
Und wenn, das wenden wir dann an. Und wenn da steht, du darfst Asylsuchende.
Auf deutschem Grund nicht abweisen, zurückweisen,
dann sagen die das, dann sagen die, der Vorgang, der hier stattgefunden hat,
der war nicht in Ordnung.
Und der war nicht in Übereinstimmung mit dem Gesetz, welches korrekt zu interpretieren unsere Aufgabe ist.
Und nicht nur korrekt so interpretieren, sondern wenn es von den Richtern so
und so interpretiert wird durch entsprechende Entscheidungen,
dann hat das so durchgeführt.
Und dann hat das auch zu passieren, das ist nicht ein Angebot,
nicht ein Angebot zur Schlichtung oder so, wo man sagen kann,
ach weißt du, sind wir anders.
Man stelle sich vor, was hier draußen auf der Straße los wäre.
Wenn jeder einfach vom Gericht was gesagt kriegt und sagt, stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das können wir so nicht machen. So können wir unseren Staat nicht lange aufrechterhalten.
Und nicht nur ignoriert jetzt der Innenminister und der Kanzler dieses Urteil?
Spezifisch, indem sie ja sagen, naja, das ist ein Einzelfallurteil und damit
sagen, das könnt ihr ja jedes Mal wieder machen und der größere Teil der Leute,
die wir hier wegschicken,
und damit gegen das Gesetz verstoßen, kommen wir nicht zurück und können hier
klagen und dann machen wir halt einfach Einzelfall jetzt raus.
Das ist ja das, was die Bundesregierung macht. Gibt da noch was anderes?
Die Richter werden jetzt bedroht.
Die werden diffamiert und bedroht, weil sie hier das gemacht haben,
was ein Richter tun soll.
Ich stelle mir das natürlich echt irre vor, wenn, was machst du andersrum?
Also es ist nicht so, als hätten die Richterinnen hier irgendeine Verantwortung oder so.
Also selbst wenn man sagen würde, wir finden das Urteil, was die gesprochen haben, nicht gut.
Dann kannst du die trotzdem nicht bedrohen. Man kann sowieso keinen bedrohen.
Aber wenn du anfängst, Richterinnen und Gerichte zu bedrohen,
dann hast du wirklich eine sehr unschöne Entwicklung in deinem Land.
Wir haben die unschöne Entwicklung schon seitdem Politiker bedroht werden.
Und da passiert auch ehrlich gesagt herzlich wenig.
Der Haselhoff hat jetzt irgendwie, also Ministerpräsident in Sachsen-Anhalt
meint, wenn die AfD da gewinnt, dann ziehe ich weg.
Ja, da wird er nicht der Einzige sein.
Nee, aber ich meine, auf dem Level findet das schon statt.
Und das ist natürlich echt das
Problem, dass der Staat sich hier nicht besonders wehrhaft präsentiert.
Gerade die CDU nicht. Ich meine, Mord an Walter Lübcke hat hier,
oder wird einer von ihren eigenen Fußsoldaten erschossen. Da halten die den Mund.
Also das ist wirklich schwer nachzuvollziehen.
In der letzten Sendung haben wir dann noch über vergleichsweise lächerliche
Nachrichten aus den USA gesprochen.
Nämlich das sich in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung zersetzende Verhältnis
zwischen Elon Musk und Donald Trump.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so war, aber ich glaube Elon Musk
hat dann irgendwann nochmal getwittert, einige Tweets sind zu weit gegangen,
er findet Donald Trump total cool.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht, ob das wiederum Fake war.
Cool, hat er glaube ich jetzt nicht geschrieben, aber er meinte,
er hätte die Tweets nicht so angemessen gewesen. Hat also den Schwanz eingetragen.
Hat er einen Moment, einen lichten Moment gehabt. Sehen wir mal.
Also zumindest dürfte ihm bedeutet worden sein, dass seine Drohung,
jetzt die Dragon Capsule, das Programm einzustellen, sich so nicht durchhalten lässt.
Und er von daher relativ wenig Leverage hat, aber das Government hat relativ viel Leverage.
Seine ganzen, also er bezieht ja Milliarden an Förderungen vom Staat,
die jetzt wahrscheinlich Trump ihm irgendwie entziehen will und die damit Tesla
noch weiter das Genick bricht.
Und andererseits kann natürlich auch die USA SpaceX weiterhin Druck machen,
weil SpaceX war ja nun sehr erfolgreich und ist natürlich auch sehr wertvoll
und Starlink und überhaupt und Dragon Capsule etc. pp.
Trotzdem lebt SpaceX nicht nur davon.
Also dieses Starlink-Programm, was sie haben, das ist ja noch nicht profitabel.
Also die haben ja nun hunderte, tausende von Satelliten ins All gebracht und
müssen das auch weiterhin tun.
Und natürlich ist das ein Business like no other und damit sind sie auch weltweit
durch, also absolut führend und in einem bestimmten Maße auch erfolgreich,
was die Adoption betrifft, nur die Kosten sind halt extrem hoch.
Und SpaceX konnte all diesen Erfolg in den letzten zehn Jahren nur dadurch realisieren,
indem sie vom US-Government sehr viele Launch-Aufträge bekommen haben.
Also das US-Government hat einfach garantiert, wir fliegen mit euch hier irgendwie
alle möglichen militärischen Satelliten,
Hochspionagesatelliten, was weiß ich, das sind immer so diese Missionen,
wo sie sagen so, ja, hier der Staat und wir fliegen irgendwas vom US-Militär hoch.
Aber wir sagen euch nicht was, weil dürfen wir nicht. Und davon gab es eine ganze Menge.
Und das ist halt auch einer der Gründe, warum es zum Beispiel in Europa nicht
so gut läuft, weil eben dem Ariane-Programm solche Zusagen nicht gemacht werden.
Ja, ich denke, dass diese gesamte Idee von Starlink,
Wenn ein Unternehmer kommt oder ein Unternehmen, privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen,
sagt, pass mal auf, wir machen hier eine weltumspannende Internetversorgung mit Satelliten.
Das ist schon relativ klar, dass da sehr viele militärische Interessen mit eine Rolle spielen.
Weil Thema Souveränität, da willst du halt schon sicherstellen,
dass dein schönes Internet für deine Drohnen, die irgendwo am anderen Ende des
Planeten den Tod bringen, dass das eben dein Internet ist und du da nicht eine
Abhängigkeit hast auf irgendjemanden, der, wie Elon Musk es ja auch schon demonstriert hat,
irgendwann im Keterrausch mal morgens sagt, ey, war das eigentlich,
wenn ich der Ukraine den Starlink ausschalte oder wieder an?
Ich habe da mal einen LKW hingeschickt, die sind mir nicht dankbar genug,
jetzt mache ich das wieder aus. Also das willst du halt nicht.
Du willst dann richtig schönen Hardcore-Militaristen, der in deinem eigenen
Interesse geostrategisch Expansion fein niedermachen denkt und dabei bleibt.
Und das denke ich ist bei diesem Starlink von vornherein immer ganz klar gewesen,
dass die USA mit dem Gewehren dieses
Systemes natürlich auch ein militärisch-strategisches Interesse verfolgen.
Ein anderes Problem ist so viel gewähren mussten sie da gar nicht das haben
die ja einfach so gemacht und die aktuelle und die internationale Weltraumpolitik.
Mit dem Fördern dieses.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob sie Starlink gefördert haben, aber sie haben halt SpaceX gefördert,
also das ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr beunruhigend für Elon Musk und ich denke
er hat jetzt einfach dann den Schwanz einziehen müssen weil wahrscheinlich ihm
mit dem Rückzug von so vielen Launches gedroht wurde, dass,
dann auch irgendwann mal so seine Vorstandsbilder...
Und der Trump verkauft einen Tesla.
Ich meine... Wird ja nicht los.
Nee, der macht sich einen Aufkleber drauf und sagt I got this from Elon before he went crazy.
Okay.
Wir wollten ja eigentlich in diese Woche kommen, wo ja Schluss mit lustig war
und in sehr kurzer Zeit Donald Trump in Los Angeles,
ein paar Proteste gegen Abschiebungen zum Anlass genommen hat,
dort das Militär im Inland gegen die eigene Bevölkerung einzusetzen.
Und das ist ja eigentlich nur jetzt, da wollten wir eigentlich hin.
Genau und vor allem nur in Kalifornien, Proteste gab es natürlich auch in anderen
Bundesstaaten, aber die werden
von Republikanern regiert, da schickt man dann nicht das Militär hin.
Es ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, das letzte Mal in den 1960er Jahren vorgekommen,
dass überhaupt der National Guard gegen die eigene Bevölkerung eingesetzt wurde
und noch nie gegen den Wunsch der jeweiligen lokalen Regierung.
Ja, der Kevin Newsom, der dort regiert,
hat gesagt, ich meine, es ist halt auch L.A., also ich meine,
da hast du schon eine Polizei, die durchaus mit einigen klarkommt,
die da nicht sich überall sofort einen Fingernagel abbricht.
Natürlich im Polizeibericht sicherlich schon, aber die sind ja schon ganz gut aufgestellt.
Es war jetzt die Situation nach absolut übereinstimmenden Einschätzungen von
allen Seiten, weil in keiner Weise in der Nähe einer Eskalation,
dass du jetzt überhaupt irgendeine Verstärkung für die Polizei brauchst,
es recht nicht vom National Guard.
Also die Nationalgarde, muss
man dazu sagen, ist ja keine, ist ja eine freiwillige Leistung in den USA.
Das Militär ist nochmal was anderes. Also es ist nicht Teil des Militärs in dem Sinne.
Also es ist Teil der militärischen Reserve, aber es ist nicht Teil der US Army so unmittelbar.
Doch klar, natürlich.
Absolut gehört der National Guard zu der jeweiligen, sei es die Luftwaffe,
zu der Marine oder zu der Armee.
Das ist ganz klar. Also die werden ja auch da ausgebildet, da kenne ich mich
zufällig ein ganz kleines bisschen. Also das sind Angehörige der bewaffneten Truppen der USA.
Das sind nicht die gleichen, die du mit einem Fallschirm und einem Messer irgendwie
in den Dschungel wirst wie Rambo.
Das sind andere Leute, anderes Vertical, aber das ist ganz klar Armee.
Und bewaffnete Kräfte unter dem Kommando und so weiter.
Aber klar, also es sind nicht die Soldaten, die du die man und deswegen ist
der Einwand natürlich, die ergänzen natürlich richtig, es sind jetzt nicht die,
die du erwarten würdest, wenn du denkst, jetzt kommt das Militär.
Also bei der Bundeswehr wären das halt ja, also aber es wäre sowas,
ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas gibt, Also es wäre nicht, ja Reservisten,
keine Ahnung, ich glaube sowas gibt es eigentlich nicht, das Äquivalent bei
der deutschen Bundeswehr.
Ich freue mich schon auf unsere Kommentare. Ich laufe hier komplett in dieser Gasse.
Nationalgarde klingt halt jetzt erstmal, wenn man das so sagt,
klingt das so wie Top-Militärs, die Elite-Einheit des Militärs.
Und das ist es halt nicht.
Das ist eine etwas komplizierte Konstruktion. weitgehend sind das sozusagen,
Freiwillige, die mobilisiert werden in einem bestimmten Fall und es ist nicht die,
aktuell unter Vertrags oder unter Profivertrag laufenden Angehörigen der US
Army, sondern es ist halt eine komplizierte Struktur, die irgendwie auch nochmal
in den Bundesstaaten verankert ist und so weiter.
Ich durchblicke das nur so begrenzt. Ich wollte nur klar machen,
wenn wir jetzt sagen, da wird die Nationalgarde aktiviert in den USA,
dann klingt das so ein bisschen so wie, jetzt kommen die Elite-Truppen der US-Armee. Das ist es nicht.
Das ist eine Reservisten-Armee.
National Guard ist hier eher zu verstehen als, also National Guard ist eine
wahrscheinlich sogar komplett falsche Übersetzung von National Guard.
Also Guard ist ja nicht eine Garde oder in der,
wie ich diesen Begriff interpretiere, nicht eine Garde, sondern ein Wächter
und wenn du beim National Guard bist, dann bist du bei dem bei den nationalen Wächtern bei den,
Wächtern zu Hause eher.
Aber trotzdem natürlich ein stolzer Angehöriger der bewaffneten Kräfte der Vereinigten Staaten.
Always ready, always there. Und die haben auch eine Don't Mill Top Level Domain.
Okay. So, jetzt hast du also eine
vom Präsidenten, von der Regierung herbeigeführte Eskalation der Gewalt.
Und natürlich kannst du in einem, ich habe mir auch gedacht,
also wenn die das Militär schicken, wäre natürlich das wirklich das richtige Bild wäre,
leergefickte Straße, niemand traut sich mehr raus, weil da draußen die Regierung
das Militär gegen die eigenen Leute einsetzt.
Passiert natürlich nicht, wenn du irgendwie mit dem National Guard irgendwo
reinfährst dann kannst du dich darauf verlassen, dass es noch irgendwie ein
paar Leute gibt, die da eine Bierflasche werfen,
lauthals protestieren, die du dann wiederum angreifen kannst,
die dann sich wehren, da hast du sofort deine wunderschönen Bilder,
und das ist das, was am Ende draußen wahrgenommen oder was du dann über Fox
News schicken kannst guck dir das an, da sind die Leute die müssen im Militär
bekämpfen, so schlimm ist das da in Los Angeles.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Guck dir diesen Newsner an, der meinte,
der hätte die Situation unter Kontrolle. Guck mal hier, was ist da für Panzer?
Da sind Panzer, da sind sogar auch Leute.
Nicht wie bei der Militärparade, wo kaum einer ist.
Ja, es ist natürlich eine mediale Inszenierung und die funktioniert in gewisser
Hinsicht, solange die Medien da mitspielen, kannst du dir vorstellen,
wie das bei Fox News aussieht.
Die schreien die ganze Zeit Ceta und Mordio und die Struktur geht auseinander
und Und das ist ja Sinn der ganzen Sache.
Die eigentliche Eskalation ist ja diese Anweisung an diese ICE-Abteilung,
halt jetzt überall so Rates durchzuführen.
Wobei sie ja mittlerweile auch schon zurückrudern müssen.
Also es gibt mittlerweile ein, das wurde ja bekannt, so ein Dekret mit,
ja bitte mal bei Hotels und bei Bauern keine Rates mehr durchführen.
Weil da haben sie jetzt so viel Backlash bekommen von ihren eigenen Donuts wahrscheinlich.
Die gesagt haben, Leute, wir kriegen jetzt hier unser Personal nicht mehr zusammen
und vor allem wir kriegen die Felder nicht mehr abgeerntet.
Das ist ja auch das Absurde. Also dieser ganze Kampf gegen die Migration und
das ist ja auch ähnlich hier in Deutschland, aber auch in Großbritannien mit
dem Brexit genauso gelaufen.
Es wird die ganze Zeit gehetzt irgendwie, ja die Leute nehmen uns hier die Jobs
weg und sind ja, oder Trump legt natürlich noch oben einen drauf und das sind
ja alles irgendwie Vergewaltiger und Kriminelle, ja nur weil sie irgendwie aus
einem anderen Land kommen.
Die Wahrheit ist,
Die Wirtschaft der USA basiert auf diesen Migranten, weil die halt die Jobs
machen, zu denen kein, in Anführungsstrichen, normaler Amerikaner bereit wäre.
Weder die Arbeit als solche, geschweige denn die Bezahlung, die dafür geleistet wird.
Also sagen wir mal nicht normale Amerikaner, sagen wir mal Trump-Wähler.
Naja, so alle normalen Amerikaner würden das halt nicht tun und du hast ja auch
in Deutschland eigentlich schon dasselbe Problem also ihr Erntehelfer,
wenn es irgendwie darum geht,
in irgendeiner Form Spargel zu ernten ja, also wenn Saison ist dann, wo kommen die her?
Die kommen aus Rumänien etc.
Ich fand diesen Begriff normaler Amerikaner so ein bisschen wenig also sozusagen Also die.
Die nicht bereit sind, einfach zu Mindestlöhnen oder unter Mindestlöhnen zu
arbeiten oder zu Bedingungen zu arbeiten, die nicht akzeptabel sind für sie.
Genau, ICE, also wird glaube ich üblicherweise auch ICE ausgesprochen,
nicht ICE, Immigration and Customs Enforcement, also ein bisschen ähnlich,
also in Deutschland wäre es der Zoll im Prinzip,
hier allerdings schon ein bisschen härter.
Die sind aufgestellt unter Homeland Security, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und
schon so ein bisschen, also sollen transnationale Kriminalität bekämpfen und ja,
dann die eigentliche, also ERO gibt es noch, die sind dafür da,
die undokumentierten Immigranten zu schnappen und festzuhalten.
Ja, also eine harte Eskalation, vor allem, weil sie es ja auch offenbar auch
angewiesen haben, dass sie halt in Broad Daylight einfach irgendwo Leute wegschnappen, kontrollieren.
Du siehst dann Aufzeichnungen, wo sie einfach irgendwelche Autos wahllos anhalten
und Leute terrorisieren.
Also da soll einfach richtig, richtig im Stadtbild auch klar sein,
hier sind jetzt Leute unterwegs und die snatchen dich einfach weg.
Und das ist natürlich klar, dass
das zu allen möglichen Eskalationen auch führt, wenn du das so machst.
Also weil Leute, wenn du in den Park gehst und zerrst da einfach irgendwelche
Leute weg, dann ist klar, dass du das dreimal machst, bis du eine Situation
hast, die du unter Einsatz von Gewalt kontrollieren musst.
Und das ist sehr, sehr, also ich schaue mir das an und ich blicke da so ein
bisschen hilflos drauf, weil so völlig klar ist,
dass diese Strategie funktioniert und auch völlig klar ist, dass das Ziel dieser
Strategie ist, dass es eine Eskalation gibt.
Und dass das Ziel dieser Strategie ist, dass du die Bilder machen kannst von
der Eskalation und dass dann die Leute da sitzen und sagen, boah,
ich wusste nicht, dass es so schlimm ist.
Und wenn wir mal weiter denken, dass ja,
das Wesen des Faschismus ist, dass du den Leuten immer wieder vor irgendwas
Neuem Angst machen musst,
und dass du eben im Prinzip dein Problem ja auch nicht lösen darfst,
was du proklamierst, weil Dann hättest du ja ein Problem gelöst und du wirst
ja nur aus Angst vor diesem Problem gewählt.
Und wenn man diese Herangehensweise sich vor Augen hält, dann macht das natürlich
völlig Sinn, jetzt solche Eskalationen herbeizuführen.
Ja, also das ist halt einfach das faschistische Playbook und das Ziel ist am
Ende die etablierten Konventionen und die normale Einhaltung der Rechtsordnung
zu unterwandern und zu sagen, ja gucke mal hier,
alles läuft hier aus dem Ruder, wir hatten ja keine andere Wahl,
das muss jetzt einfach mal anders laufen und wir brauchen jetzt hier irgendwie
einen Führer mit starker Hand, Weil mit der alten Methode geht es ja nicht.
Deswegen labert er ja auch die ganze Zeit immer von, ja, hier die beiden Regierungen
hat ja alles irgendwie komplett falsch gemacht und so weiter.
Das ist immer wieder dasselbe Spiel.
Ja, schön wäre, wenn wir uns das jetzt angucken und schaffen in irgendeiner
Weise, dass man daraus zu lernen, wenn das demnächst jemand bei uns versucht.
Ja gut, also ich meine, wir lernen da ja auch draus, aber du weißt ja,
wie das ist, die meisten Leute...
Ja, okay, wir lernen, also lernen wir wirklich daraus oder lernen wir gerade
Fußball spielen von der Seitenlinie?
Weil in Deutschland sitzen und schlau drüber reden ist auch nochmal was anderes
als quasi ankündigen und sagen, wenn die AfD hier in die Macht kommt, bin ich als erstes weg.
Was ich so auch sagen würde.
Ja, das ist, vielleicht stehen wir nur daneben.
Wir thematisieren das jetzt hier auch einfach nur mal, um einfach diesen Prozess
mal beschrieben zu haben. Das findet einfach statt.
Das ist nicht sonderlich überraschend, weil man sollte jetzt eigentlich von
nichts mehr überrascht sein, was die Trump-Regierung anstrebt.
Und sie erweitern damit natürlich auch den globalen Rahmen des Möglichen.
Dieses Overtone-Window.
Man schafft damit ja sozusagen eine Stimmung, in der Leute immer bereit sind,
auch abweichendes Verhalten zu akzeptieren, was vielleicht bis dahin nicht akzeptabel war.
Und man setzt sich damit eben auch über Konventionen und im Zweifelsfall dann
eben auch über Rechtsordnung hinweg.
Weil man ja immer sagt, ja es war ja ein Notwehr, weil wir hatten ja eine Notlage.
Schon diese ganzen Zölle, die die Trump-Regierung verabschiedet hat,
sind ja rechtlich gesehen als nur deshalb vom Präsidenten überhaupt bestimmbar gewesen,
wenn man eine Notlage deklariert.
Und das stand sozusagen am Anfang. Ja, wir haben ja eine Notlage.
Ja, was ist denn die Notlage? Ja, die Notlage ist, die bescheißen uns alle.
Und auch dort sind ja die Gerichte dagegen vorgegangen, haben gesagt,
habt ihr das doch alle? Das ist doch keine Notlage.
Nur mittlerweile sind natürlich auch die Gerichte so weit weg,
eingeschüchtert erst mal durch Leute, die von Trump schon mal eingesetzt worden
sind und davon profitieren etc.
Oder eben auch durch die vorhin schon angesprochene Bedrohung von Richtern,
dass viele halt auch einfach sagen, ja okay, ist zwar hier mein Job,
aber was hilft es mir, wenn ich jetzt auch noch auf der Straße abgeknallt werde.
Und jetzt hatten wir ja auch noch, müssen wir auch noch erwähnen in diesem Zusammenhang,
diesen Mord an der demokratischen Politikerin in Minnesota, die mit ihrem Mann
zusammen einfach abgeknallt wurde von so einem Typen.
Den sie jetzt wohl gefangen haben. Haben sie gefangen, okay,
haben sie vor ein paar Stunden gekriegt.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie das ausgeht. Aber halt auch wieder so ein Trump-Wähler
und so weiter und das ist natürlich auch klar, wie das läuft.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, ob sich Trump genötigt sah,
sich da überhaupt mal qualifiziert zu äußern.
So weit sind wir noch nicht, dass er das gut finden darf.
Aber die nächsten Sätze werden natürlich dann irgendwie kommen und sagen, das ist,
noch drei, vier Politiker-Morde weiter und ein paar Monate wird sowas kommen
wie, es ist sehr tragisch, dass diese Person sich so weit getrieben hat,
dass Leute sie töten mussten.
Ja, genau.
Das wird dann, das wird alles so noch kommen.
Naja, und stattdessen setzen sie sich dann halt in ihre schlecht besuchte Parade
da auf ihre Wippsessel und gucken sich irgendwie Militärparaden an.
Und reden uns weiter Probleme ein, die keine sind.
Übrigens ähnlich wie, nur um die Parallele zu zeigen, ne, Dobrindt,
der dann jetzt seinen Verfassungsschutzbericht vorstellt, wo,
Da gibt es irgendwie ein bisschen Lagerbericht, dann gibt es jedes Jahr irgendwelche
polizeilichen Statistiken, in den Statistiken gibt es dann mal irgendwelche Spikes, zum Beispiel,
da hat sich ein Wert stark verändert,
von 40.000 bis auf 60.000 stark rechtsextremistische Personen in Deutschland,
hat also zugenommen, darunter 15.000 Gewaltbereite.
Die Straftaten sind um 50% angestiegen, Gewalt um 11% angestiegen und dann malt
er da seine Grafiken und sagt, ja also gefährlich ist nach wie vor hier die Linken.
Der gewaltorientierte Linksextremismus.
Und der ist nämlich deutlich gestiegen,
deutlich gestiegen, von 11.200 auf 11.200.
Das ist ja krass.
Ja, und das heißt, wir verlinken da mal auf den Volksverpetzer,
die das schön analysiert haben, aber auch Arne Semsrott hat das irgendwie an
unterschiedlichen Stellen auseinandergenommen.
Da wird also eine völlig erkennbar und die Korrelation zu dem Erstarken der
AfD ist alles da und der eigene Innenminister erzählt dir einfach irgendetwas komplett anderes. Tja.
Aber wir müssen noch ein Thema behandeln, von dem, da habe ich jetzt wirklich
sehr wenig Ahnung von, das ist ähnlich wie die Eskalation in den USA,
die wir ohne Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit mal zumindest erwähnen und,
aus einer Metaperspektive ein bisschen betrachten möchten, hat,
Israel.
Atomwaffen Atomanlagen Anlagen im Iran angegriffen, die im Verdacht stehen,
einen Beitrag dazu zu leisten, dass der Iran Uran anreichert und zwar auf ein Niveau,
das nicht nur für die Energiegewinnung notwendig ist, sondern eben auch waffentauglich ist.
Man muss Uran sehr stark anreichern, damit man eine Bombe bauen kann.
Mit geringeren Anreicherungen kannst du dann eben Kraftwerke und ähnliches betreiben.
Dass der Iran im Verdacht steht, eine Bombe anzustreben, ist so seit den 1960er Jahren Thema.
Und die aktivere Auseinandersetzung damit verfolge ich spätestens seit Stuxnet.
Stuxnet wurde übrigens vor sehr genau 15 Jahren, also am 17.
Juni 2010 entdeckt. Das war eine Schadsoftware,
die geeignet war, bestimmte Urananreicherungszentrifugen, ich glaube sogar von Siemens.
Zu manipulieren, dass sie so leichte Ungleichmäßigkeiten hatten,
obwohl sie quasi andere Werte geliefert haben.
Und das hat dann diesen Anreicherungsprozess gestört.
Interessant ist das aber deshalb gewesen, weil diese Anreicherungsanlagen ja
airgap betrieben werden und man irgendwie da rein musste.
Und deswegen hatten sie als Infektionsweg einen Bug im USB-Storage oder USB-Treiber
von Microsoft Windows direkt drin.
Und die Idee war offenbar irgendwie zu erkennen,
ob man in einer Anreicherungsanlage ist und dann potenziell dort diese Schadsoftware
zur Manipulation der Anlage zur Anreicherung auch wirksam zu machen und ansonsten nichts zu tun.
Aber irgendwie wurde es dann entdeckt, da gibt es spannende Vorträge,
da gab es beim CCC Kongress einen Vortrag von demjenigen, einem Microsoft-Techniker,
der das analysiert hatte, diese Schwachstelle.
Und dann gibt es auch von anderen Leuten wie Frank Boldewin und anderen Security-Forschern,
die diese Software damals analysiert hatten, sehr spannende Auseinandersetzungen zu.
Das heißt, vor 15 Jahren schon hat Israel vermutlich in Zusammenarbeit mit den
USA die zu dem Zeitpunkt auf jeden Fall bei weitem advancedeste Cyberwaffe zum Einsatz gebracht.
Mit einem O-Day, mit krassestem Engineering, um spezifisch diese Anreicherung da zu stören.
Und das heißt, so viel Interesse hatten die schon vor 15 Jahren daran,
dass dieses Atomprogramm nicht in einer Bombe mündet, was, das sage ich jetzt
erstmal sehr vorsichtig, ich als Ziel durchaus teile.
Also ich glaube, es ist auch für viele besser, wenn der Iran keine Atombombe hat.
Das heißt natürlich nicht, weil hier endet auch mein Wissen,
jetzt hat Israel also Luftangriffe anscheinend ziemlich gezielt gegen diese Anlagen vorgenommen,
wo man sagen muss, dass zumindest nicht klar ist, ob die wirklich auch militärisch genutzt werden.
Es wäre theoretisch auch denkbar, dass es sich hier um zivile Anlagen handelt
und Israel unprovoziert einen Angriff auf den Iran vorgenommen hat.
Iran hat ja nicht gesagt, ich baue eine Bombe und knall euch weg, wir sind bald fertig.
Zumindest habe ich das nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, also gut, das ist ja immer eine Interpretationssache. Also Iran hat sich
ja, sagen wir mal, schon immer sehr explizit zu ihrer Meinung zu Israel geäußert
und unterstützt die Vernichtung des Staates.
Ja, das ist sozusagen das Ziel, dass der Erzfeind und Israel darf nicht existieren.
Und da muss man jetzt nicht so viel zusammenrechnen, um zu sehen,
dass wenn sie da Atomanlagen bauen,
deren Kontrolle sie versuchen zu verhindern, die 90 Meter unter der Erde liegen
mit mehreren Betonschichten darüber, um die möglichst bombenfest zu machen,
dass das so ein bisschen fishy ist.
Ich war nicht, ich habe da keine unmittelbaren Erkenntnisse dazu.
Tut jetzt auch erstmal überhaupt nichts zur Sache.
Was halt jetzt passiert ist, das Ganze steht ja auch jetzt in einer Kette von Ereignissen,
die quasi mit diesem Terroranschlag der Hamas begonnen hat.
Angriff auf Israel, Israel auf dem linken Fuß erwischt worden über tausend Tote
und dann haben wir gesehen, der genauso fatale.
Angriff auf Gaza, der ja immer noch anhält, die Vernichtung der kompletten Hisbollah-Führung
und im Nachhinein auch die Vernichtung von gut zwei Drittel der Raketenkapazität der Hisbollah.
Damit hat sich dann Israel halt eines großen Problems, eines weiteren großen
Problems schon dann entledigt.
Und dann halt auch noch der Sturz von Assad, den ja Israel dann auch sofort genutzt hat,
um die restlichen Militärfähigkeiten Syriens vollständig auszulöschen,
also die komplette Vernichtung der Luftabwehr Syriens.
Und das hat jetzt den Boden bereitet, dass Israel mit seinen Kampfflugzeugen
bis an die Grenze des Iran fliegen kann, was vorher nicht möglich war.
Und das war jetzt die militärische Situation, in der sich Israel befand.
Und den Plan gegen diese Anlagen im Iran vorzugehen, den dürften sie schon seit
vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren ausgearbeitet haben.
Nur weil er vorbereitet wird, heißt es ja nicht, dass er dann auch exekutiert
wird, sondern dazu müssen diese Rahmenbedingungen stimmen. Und die Rahmenbedingungen waren jetzt da.
Schwache USA mit einem völlig hirntoten Präsidenten, dem alles irgendwie egal
ist, indem man am Ende nur genug Kohle oder Schmeicheleien um die Ohren hauen
muss, um ihn irgendwo hinzubekommen.
Die militärischen Voraussetzungen und natürlich dann auch die Bedrohungslage,
die Israel selber sieht.
Und man muss einfach akzeptieren, dass Israel diese Bedrohung sehr ernst nimmt.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du jetzt in so einem Land leben würdest,
wo dann tausend Kilometer weiter ein anderes Land ist, was dir die ganze Zeit
die Vernichtung wünscht und was fleißig dabei ist, Atomanlagen zu bauen,
da würde ich dann auch ein bisschen stutzig werden. Naja, man kann es jetzt bewerten, wie man will.
Tatsache ist, dieser Angriff hat stattgefunden und es ist natürlich erstmal
auch nicht nur ein Angriff auf die Atomanlagen, sondern damit dieser Angriff
auf die Atomanlagen stattfinden kann,
haben sie als erstes die Luftverteidigung Irans ausgeschaltet,
sie haben irgendwie eine Enthauptungsstrategie gemacht, sie haben halt irgendwie
die Chefs der Luftwaffe, Chef der,
nicht der normalen Streitkräfte, sondern der.
Also sowohl jetzt neuerdings auch dieser Al-Quds-Brigaden,
aber eben auch dem Kaminé, also dem Nationalgarde, die sozusagen dem Kaminé unterstellt ist.
Was nochmal was anderes ist als die normale Armee Irans, die sehr viel skeptischer
dem Regime gegenüber steht, die sie nicht so getroffen haben.
Auf jeden Fall, das war die Strategie.
Dann war die Luft frei und jetzt erleben wir seit drei Tagen ein permanentes
Bombardement und da wird jetzt gar nichts verschont.
Vor allem geht es in Israel halt um dieses Atomprogramm, aber es geht ihnen
natürlich jetzt auch um das Problem der ballistischen Raketen,
wo Iran ein riesiges Arsenal zu haben scheint.
Und deswegen findet jetzt As We Speak vor allem gerade die Jagd auf diese mobilen
Raketenlauncher statt.
Und das ist so der Zwischenstand in diesem Konflikt.
Und das geht einfach heiß her und es werden sehr viele Raketen auf Israel abgeschossen
und da ist jetzt auch gerade die Luftverteidigung Israels so ein bisschen an seine Grenzen.
Also man merkt, jetzt sind sie nicht mehr in der Lage alles abzufangen und Und
einige Raketen sind halt jetzt auch in Israel in den großen Städten runtergegangen.
In Haifa haben sie eine große Fabrik getroffen. In Tel Aviv haben sie diverse
Wohnhäuser zerballert.
Und das ist halt jetzt einfach die Situation gerade, dieses Krieg.
Also als Management-Summary, was da gerade so passiert, verfolgt das natürlich
genau, weil das natürlich auch irgendwie in das ganze internationale Krisengeschehen mit reinspielt.
Und vor allem ist halt die große Frage, wird die USA in diesen Konflikt jetzt
mit eintreten oder nicht?
Weil bisher haben sie sich herausgehalten und Trump sagt, ja nee,
wir haben da nichts zu tun. Das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Zumindest haben sie es nicht verhindert. Ich meine, die USA hat immer eine Möglichkeit,
Israel von irgendetwas abzuhalten.
Wenn Israel von irgendwas nicht abgehalten wird, dann heißt es,
dass die USA das dann nicht wollte.
Im Gegenteil, gab es ja glaube ich nachher die Berichte, dass die USA ein paar
Tage vorher da ihr Botschaftspersonal an unterschiedlichen Standorten schon
mal ein bisschen reduziert haben.
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Berichte, auch dass sie, dass es auch Undercover Raketenlieferungen
gegeben hat, von Hellfire-Raketen, das ist alles so ein bisschen unbestätigt,
deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber,
natürlich Israel und USA sind sich sehr nah. Das ist gar keine Frage.
Aber auch ähnlich kriminelle Staatsoberhäupter.
Das ist derzeit so ein Trend. Leider ist das so.
Wobei man ja glaube ich Israel anders bewerten muss als die USA. Naja.
Die Frage ist,
werden die USA in diese Kampagne noch mit einsteigen oder nicht?
Das stellt sich halt vor allem deshalb, weil so fähig die israelische Armee
ist und das sieht man, dass sie,
eine der fähigsten Armeen dieser ganzen Welt ist, weil das, was sie dann gerade,
geheimdienstechnisch abgezogen haben und auch,
militärstrategisch gemacht haben, das ist halt einfach Masterclass,
das kann man einfach nicht anders sagen, also rein aus einer militärischen Bewertung
heraus, Masterclass, die wissen, wo alle Führungspersonen sich aufhalten des Irans.
Sie kennen alle Standorte und sie haben halt jetzt so eine Lufthoheit im Iran
und können da irgendwie stundenlang Einsätze fahren.
Das werden sie jetzt noch vier, fünf Tage durchhalten können in dieser Intensität
und dann wird es halt interessant zu sehen, ob sie bis dahin es geschafft haben, die,
Möglichkeit des Iran weiter Raketen zu schicken nach Israel, ob sie das ausreichend,
eingefangen bekommen haben. Nach fünf Tagen müssen sie einfach mal ihre Kampfflugzeuge
auch mal warten. Die können nicht permanent fliegen.
Fünf Tage brauchen alle fünf Tage Wartung, das ist ja schlimmer als ein alter Golf.
Na eigentlich noch häufiger, also moderne Kampfflugzeuge müssen eigentlich nach
jedem Einsatz gefahren werden.
Die fahren jetzt natürlich alles maximal auf Kante,
aber wenn du nach einer Woche nicht mal deine Intensität, 60 Prozent der gesamten
Luftwaffe Israels ist da gerade im Einsatz, 60 Prozent, das ist richtig viel.
Einen Teil musst du immer irgendwie in der Wartung haben und sie müssen natürlich
auch noch eine Reserve haben, wenn jetzt irgendwie von woanders noch eine Bedrohung kommt.
Tim, ich wusste nicht, dass du so viel Ahnung von dem Thema hast.
Ich hoffe, das wird in der ... Da gibt es wahrscheinlich bald ein UKW?
Ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Ich dachte, wir erwähnen mal gerade ganz kurz, dass der Marker in den ...
Ja, aber es ist wichtig, zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, dass es eigentlich ist das,
einer der krassesten Militärkonflikte, der hätte ausbrechen können.
Und die USA kriegt das nicht mehr contained.
Und deswegen sah sich jetzt Israel in der Lage, das so durchzuziehen.
Auch eben, weil die ganze Voraussetzungen dafür gegeben waren.
Ob das sich am Ende als eine gute Idee herausstellen wird, I don't know.
Das bleibt dann der Welt übrig in der Bewertung, aber aufhalten wird man sie
jetzt erstmal nicht können.
Okay, also auch da interessante Neuigkeiten.
Und die Frage, ob die USA mit einsteigen, hat halt viel damit zu tun,
ob sie jetzt auch wirklich die finale Zerstörung dieses Atombombenprogramms
haben wollen, weil das, was derzeit noch nicht angegriffen ist,
kann Israel vermutlich nicht zerstören mit dem Waffenarsenal,
was sie haben. Das können nur die Amerikaner.
Nur die Amerikaner haben diese krassen, mega bunkerbrechenden Waffen,
mit denen man eben auch noch so tief in der Erde alles zermalmen kann.
Und du meinst, sie haben sich nicht vorher vergewissert und gesagt,
pass auf, lieber Amerikaner, das wäre schon ganz gut, wir legen das jetzt mal
frei und dann könnt ihr da so eine Rakete reinschießen?
Naja, weißt du, Trump will ja mit nichts zu tun haben. Er will ja irgendwie
Frieden über die Welt bringen.
Und der hat auch keine Ahnung von solchen Konflikten. Ich meine,
das sind alles, in der Trump-Regierung sind halt nur Anfänger.
Der hat da seine Golf-Buddies, hat er da irgendwie. Dieser Witkow,
der für den Austenkonflikt zuständig ist, das ist sein Golf-Buddy.
Das ist irgendwie ein Immobilienmakler.
Das sind die Leute, die sich jetzt um die internationale Konfliktbetreuung kümmern
und irgendwie mit den Russen verhandeln.
Das ist einfach, also diese ganze Trump-Riege, das ist einfach alles Vollidioten
und Anfänger und man kann ihn noch nicht mal als Anfänger nennen,
weil die einfach überhaupt gar keine Chance haben,
in dieses Thema mit reinzusteigen und deswegen ist das ja auch so absurd.
Sich da jetzt mit irgendwelchen Leuten auseinander, die ein Leben lang Netanyahu.
Ich meine Putin, das sind einfach Lavrov, sein Außenminister,
das sind einfach alles gehärtete Vollprofis,
das sind einfach Hardcore-Politiker und Hardcore-Strategen in diesem Weltgeschehen,
die kennen alles und alle Tricks und das sind einfach geheimdienstgestärkte
Typen und da kommt halt irgendwie Trump mit seinen,
Vollidioten irgendwie aus seinem Mar-a-Lago irgendwie Beach Club und will da
mitspielen mit seinen Mafia-Methoden.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das am Anfang haben die wahrscheinlich alle
so gedacht, okay scheiße, die sind echt gut, die spielen so überzeugend den
Idioten. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Nein, das ist einfach eine Laientruppe und das ist ja das Absurde.
Die können halt nur dieses faschistische Playbook irgendwie super spielen,
weil es ihnen dann auch einfach zu einfach gemacht wird durch die Medien und
das Ganze noch angeheizt durch diese Social,
Mediasierung der Welt, sodass halt einfach Leute ...
Ja, keiner glaubt mehr was, weil es eben diesen Playern gelingt,
Misstrauen zu sehen. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Und alle, die halt das Lied des Misstrauens mitsingen, sind halt die Profiteure,
werden dann von Leuten in Machtstellungen
gewählt und da wird dann am Ende aber keiner was von haben.
Das ist sozusagen die große Welle, die gesamtpolitisch auf dieser Welt umgedreht werden muss.
Wir müssen wieder in so ein Vertrauensverhältnis zu unseren Institutionen kommen,
Vertrauen in den Staat, Vertrauen in das System,
Vertrauen in die Gerichtsbarkeit, Vertrauen in die Politiker,
dass sie sich auch daran halten, Vertrauen in eine Bundeswehr,
Vertrauen in alles mögliche.
Und das wird schwierig werden und unter Umständen wird es sehr lange dauern,
bis wir da wieder hinkommen.
Mit dem Personal schon mal nicht.
Nee.
Wir brauchen jetzt mal ein bisschen leichteres Thema.
Was? Noch leichter?
Es gibt eine Hotelkette mit dem Namen Numa.
Und das ist ein Hotel, hier in Vorbereitung, wenn dann Eis irgendwann alle weggestreckt hat.
Ja, das ist auch genau der, das ist zum Beispiel total scheiße, sowas zu machen.
Ja, jetzt haben die alle den scheiß Ohrwurm und das einzige,
was hilft, ist ein belegtes Brot mit Schinken. Numa ist ein Hotel ohne Rezeption.
Man muss da online einschenken.
Also Rezeptionsmitarbeiter ist schon mal gespart.
Und Cantorke hatte irgendwie, Booking.com Hotel hatte dann da so ein Numa gebucht.
Und wenn man da einchecken möchte, muss man das eben online machen,
weil es keine Rezeption gibt.
Und dann gibt es, da musst du sagen, ja ich bin da und so weiter.
Und einer davon ist, du musst digitale Identität nachweisen.
Und da sagen sie, wir können jetzt entweder so ein Video-Interview machen,
wo du, ne, so Kamera und so weiter.
Wo ich mir auch denke, so beknackt.
Also diese Video-Interviews sind natürlich auch, die kostet ja auch ein Schweinegeld.
Da kannst du, aber klar, da hast du wahrscheinlich irgendwie einen Sitz,
der sitzt dann irgendwo da, wo es günstiger ist, als da, wo die Rezeption steht.
Naja, und dann sagen sie, aber du kannst auch einfach mal zum Beispiel Foto
von deinem Ausweis hochladen.
Hier, machst ein Foto von deinem Ausweis, lädst du bei uns hoch,
dann kriegst du dein Hotelzimmer.
Dann hat Kantorger sich gesagt, nee, das möchte ich beides nicht,
dann storniere ich die Buchung.
Ne, so weil es für den Termin Videocall gab es keinen Termin mehr,
hochladen ging nicht mehr, hat er gesagt, alles klar, stornieren dann haben
wir gesagt, okay, kannst ja stornieren, hat er gesagt, gut, dann stornieren wir das jetzt,
und dann durfte er die Stornierung beantragen und dann haben die gesagt,
ja, nee ja, hat nicht geklappt du,
ja Fehler, Fehler 10 Fehler hast du nicht geklappt, nicht so,
wir haben das abgelehnt, dass wir das, äh dass wir das zulassen.
Irgend so ein Skript ist gescheitert in dieser ganzen Automatisierung.
Also hat er gesagt, na gut, dann checke ich halt ein. Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Gab es irgendwie ein paar Fehler. Irgendwann konnte er einchecken.
Und dann haben sie ihn reingelassen. Dann war er in einem Hotel.
So, jetzt war er aber natürlich schlecht gelaunt in dem Hotel.
So. Und das ist zum Beispiel auch, wo du merkst, da haben sich halt Anfänger
mit einem Profi eingelassen und es wäre klüger gewesen, einfach zu sagen,
stornieren, kein Thema.
Hier, zack, verpiss dich, geh woanders schlafen, ist mir egal. Ciao.
Kakao. Aber was machen die?
Schicken ihm eine Rechnung und sagen, hier kannst du deine Rechnung runterladen.
Und die Rechnung war unter https, trip, numasys.com, API Invoice Download,
Fragezeichen, Trip-ID, hast du nicht gesehen, Invoice-ID und dann steht da eine Nummer.
Und was machst du? Sagst du halt natürlich, was ist denn, wenn ich die Nummer,
die da hinten steht bei der Invoice-ID, ja, die steht ja auch in meiner Rechnung.
Oh, ich habe eine Rechnung.
Rechnungsnummern müssen in Deutschland aufsteigend vergeben werden.
Die fortlaufend vergeben werden müssen und wenn der Download-Link ist,
Invoice-ID und da steht nur die Rechnungsnummer, dann sagst du halt,
was ist denn mit der Rechnung? Ein hoch, ein runter. Und dann stellst du fest, es gibt weitere Gäste,
und kannst dann eben mit einer kleinen Stichprobe von ein paar tausend lädst
dir halt alle möglichen Rechnungsnummern, Rechnungen herunter.
In der Rechnung steht eine Buchungsnummer,
und über diese Buchungsnummer kommst du dann wiederum auf dieses Check-in-Formular,
wo du dann die personenbezogene Daten aus den Ausweisen und die entsprechenden Dinge findest.
Mit Adresse und allem.
Und eben auch die Ausweisdaten von den Leuten. Alles nur durch einfaches Hoch- und Runterzählen.
Ich weiß nicht, was waren das jetzt? Wie viele? Irgendwie halbe Million oder sowas betroffen?
Das war seine Schätzung. Er hat nicht alle runtergeladen. Er hat es mal mit
so zehn probiert, die er so random rausgewählt hat.
Und das war dann schon Beweis genug.
Aber da diese Rechnungsnummer halt schon sehr hochgezählt war,
davon ausgehend, dass da schon so einiges stattgefunden hat. ja.
Übrigens, needless to say, die Leute irgendwie Ausweise hochladen zu lassen
und die zu speichern, ist glaube ich sowieso nicht akzeptabel.
Also das hättest du nie sammeln und verarbeiten dürfen.
Ich meine, es ist halt wieder so ein Fall von irgendwie scheiß programmiert,
kann man jetzt echt nicht anders sagen. Ich meine, so eine Sachen.
Wenn das irgendein Hotel gewesen wäre, die nicht sagen, unser Kernfeature ist
ein digitaler Check-in und die Lösung, die wir dazu haben ist,
lad mal bitte, mach mal ein Foto von deinem Ausweis, lad das hoch, wir speichern das hier.
Es ist wirklich mit der Kompetenz und so.
Ja, der Artikel von, also es gibt einmal einen Post bei ccc.de,
ich glaube, es gab einen Zeitartikel und dann gab es auch von kann Torke noch
einen privaten Blogpost unter dem Titel Numa Numa Ne Numa Numa Ne weil er möchte
natürlich nicht nochmal hin,
So, dann hat man in Italien entfaltet sich gerade so ein klitzekleiner Staatstrojaner-Skandal.
Und es wurde dort die Spionagesoftware Graphite festgestellt im Einsatz gegen
Aktivisten und Journalisten.
Die Software wird bereitgestellt von dem Unternehmen Paragon Solutions,
die in USA und Israel offenbar ansässig sind. Und das hat natürlich schon irgendwie
zu Diskussionen geführt.
Bei den Aktivisten handelt es sich um Leute, die im Bereich der Migration und
Migrationskontrolle aktivistisch tätig sind.
Und bei dem Journalisten Francesco Cancelato, der betreibt die Webseite fanpage.it,
die sich sehr regelmäßig kritisch über die Meloni-Regierung äußert.
Jetzt hat das Citizen Lab festgestellt, dass zwei weitere Journalisten mit dieser
Schadsoftware infiziert wurden.
Einmal Ciro Pellegrino, das ist auch jemand, der bei Fanpage schreibt und ein
weiterer prominenter europäischer Journalist, der gerne anonym bleiben möchte
und alle von dem gleichen Angreifer.
So, und dann gab es eine Stellungnahme von Paragon Solutions, die sagen.
Wir haben, also wir, der Hersteller dieser Schadsoftware, haben sowohl der italienischen
Regierung als auch dem Parlament eine Möglichkeit angeboten,
um festzustellen, ob sein System unter Verstoß gegen geltendes italienisches
Recht oder unsere Vertragsbedingungen gegen Journalisten eingesetzt wurde.
Also sie haben gesagt, ihr könnt das hier gerne euch angucken und prüfen.
Missbrauch mit unserer Dienstleistung. Die nennen das ja Produkt,
aber es ist ja eine Dienstleistung.
Betrieben wurde. Und da haben die italienischen Behörden gesagt,
nö, nö, das interessiert uns nicht.
Und daraufhin hat Paragon den Vertrag gekündigt.
Das ist nach meiner Kenntnis das erste Mal, dass so etwas vorkommt.
Offenbar will Paragon einen guten Eindruck machen.
Und hier ein Exempel statuieren, dass sie ihr Produkt tatsächlich nur an die
Guten für das Gute verkaufen.
Nehmen wir mal so zur Kenntnis, also auf jeden Fall eine, also nach meiner,
ich wüsste nicht, dass das schon mal vorgekommen wäre.
Also das möchte ich jetzt auch nicht großartig als besonders lobenswert,
ja vorher war es immer noch falsch,
Schadsoftware zu machen, aber immerhin hat dieses Unternehmen irgendwo noch ethische Standards.
Also sie sind ja aus den USA. Auf ihrer Webseite prangt groß ein Empowering Ethical Cyber Defense.
Also das ist so ihr Claim.
Interessant, dass die italienische Regierung sich nicht dazu äußert,
dass sie die Ethical Cyber Defense kaufen und ihnen nichts besseres einfällt,
als irgendwie ein paar Aktivisten und ein paar Journalisten,
die kritisch über die Regierung schreiben, anzugreifen.
Und dann gibt es noch eine kurze Nachricht von der Innenministerkonferenz.
Seit inzwischen 2021 wird ja bemängelt, dass die Polizei trotz Kenntnis davon,
dass auf bestimmten Shared Hosts dokumentierter Kenntnismissbrauch liegt,
sich nicht um dessen Löschung bemüht.
Und die Beschlussvorlage der Innenministerkonferenz ist,
sie sollen weiterhin nicht verpflichtet werden, a, systematisch nach sowas zu
suchen und b, auf eine Löschung hinzuwirken.
Aber die Drogenmärkte, da wird jede Woche,
als Cybermarkt, da wird jede Woche ein neuer Erfolg gefeiert,
also die Fähigkeiten hätten, haben sie ja offenbar auch besser gegen solche.
Darknet-Angebote vorzugehen.
Aber im Bereich der des dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs sagen sie ja,
sie wollen das dann irgendwie überwachen.
Das deckt sich ja aber nicht mit der Recherche von 2021 von Daniel Moosbrugger,
wo nämlich genau nicht überwacht wird und auch nicht irgendwie quasi die Provider
darauf hingewiesen werden, dass man ihnen sagt, hier, passt mal auf,
seht mal bitte zu, wer darauf zugreift oder so.
Also das hat mich in keiner Form überzeugt, was da seit vielen Jahren passiert.
Aber warum die Innenministerkonferenz das vorschlägt?
Sie sagen, sie würden das überwachen.
Ja, aber...
Aber tun sie ja nicht.
Ja.
Aber das ist die Begründung.
So, damit sind wir bei den Terminen. und es gibt sogar einen Termin,
da wird der Tim hingehen.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben das letzte Mal schon angekündigt. Machen wir jetzt
nochmal. Oder haben wir das nicht gemacht?
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Was, das haben wir nicht gemacht?
Nein. Das ist ja das... Oder haben wir das letzte Mal? Nein,
es steht nicht in den Shownotes.
Dann haben wir es vergessen. Das ist natürlich blöd. Aber macht ja nichts.
Ist ja noch genug Zeit von heute aus zehn Tage, nämlich in,
Wien findet eine Jubiläumsfeier statt von nichts Geringerem als Epicenter Works.
Grüße an Thomas Lohninger, der
uns ja hier schon oft von dem Schaffen von Epicenter hier berichtet hat.
Und wir haben das natürlich auch ohne ihn auch immer wieder mal darauf hingewiesen,
was dort alles passiert. Und ja, jetzt gibt es eine Jubiläumsfeier.
15 Jahre der Existenz werden gefeiert. Das Ganze findet statt am 26.
Juni, so ab 18 Uhr, im Ankersaal Kulturhaus Brotfabrik.
Muss man die ganze Adresse noch dazu nennen. Das ist auf jeden Fall in Wien.
Absberg 27 Stiege 3 Slash dritter Stock.
In Wien kannst du nicht schnell verlaufen.
1-1-0-0 Wien, das ist im Elften.
Das ist wahrscheinlich im Bezirk.
Kann man das aus der Postleitzahl herauslesen?
Keine Ahnung, ich dachte, da war jetzt eine Elfte.
Das ist ein bisschen zu einfach.
Das habe ich eh nicht ganz verstanden. Das hat Thomas mir schon öfter mal in Wien erzählt.
Aber hier Brotfabrik finde ich jetzt irgendwas in Prenzlauer Berg.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es ein tolles Programm mit spannenden Vorträgen aus Politik,
Wissenschaft und Zivilgesellschaft und es gibt auch ein Unterhaltungsprogramm mit guter Musik.
Genaue Angaben haben wir nicht, aber mir hat es gereicht zu sagen, da gehe ich hin.
Genau, das ist Epicenter Works.
Vor 15 Jahren hießen die hoffentlich wahrscheinlich noch Ackervorrat Österreich.
Ich glaube, dass die Umbenennung in Epicenter… Ist nicht 15 Jahre her.
Ne?
Nee, also hoffentlich nicht, sonst zweifle ich langsam auch an meinem Alter.
Kleine Studentenbewegung gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung ging es los.
Jetzt ein etablierter, gemeinnütziger Verein für digitale Grundrechte.
Das ist durchaus eine krasse Entwicklung, die diese Organisation gemacht hat
und die natürlich Thomas da,
maßgeblich vorangetrieben hat, der diese Organisation zu dem gemacht hat, was sie ist.
Dezember 2016 ist die Umbenennung erfolgt.
Und das denke ich ist das wird das kann man feiern, das wird auch sicherlich
eine sehr schöne Festlichkeit, zu der wir sehr raten sie zu besuchen.
Genau.
Ja, das war es dann auch erstmal von uns.
Ich kann leider nicht, ich bin da bei der Fusion.
Tja, Prioritäten.
Ja, aber das sage ich auch erst jetzt, weil bei der Fusion gibt es eh keine
Tickets mehr. Das heißt, damit grätsch ich Thomas jetzt nicht rein.
Ist auch, glaube ich, nicht so ganz die gleiche Zielgruppe. Ja,
super, ich würde mich auf jeden Fall freuen, euch da zu treffen.
Falls Hörer von LNP vor Ort sind, es soll ja Überschneidungen geben da im Publikum,
dann sagt Hallo, wenn ihr mich seht.
Es ist ja keine Konkurrenz zu Thomas',
Veranstaltung. Einen Tag später am 27.06.
Gibt es bei der Fusion am Freitag am Actionhaber ein kleines bisschen Programm,
was kuratiert wurde von mir und ein paar anderen Leuten.
Ach, guck an.
Ja, und da gibt es einige Leute zu sehen.
Also dieser Hinweis richtet sich jetzt nur an die Fusion-Besucherinnen,
aber das wird da sehr spannend.
Da sind Leute, die waren viele der Leute, die dort sein werden,
waren bei LMP schon zu Gast.
Fast alle der Leute, die dort da sein werden, waren schon mal Speakerinnen auf dem CCC-Kongress.
Und...
Ist aber geheim, oder was wäre das?
Ich bin gerade so am Rumirren, ob ich das jetzt nachher irgendwie,
ob ich nachher Ärger kriege, weil ich Fusion-Programm geleakt habe.
Also deswegen bin ich gerade so vorsichtig. Aber ich sag mal...
Ich kann ja einfach mal nur Titel sagen.
Genau, das mache ich jetzt mal. Ich sage einfach mal, was da so für Themen behandelt werden.
Und dann könnt ihr ja raten, wer da ist, wer da sein wird.
Also das ganze Konzept ist der Hafen der Zukunft.
Es gibt Formate, die sich mit Zukunft auseinandersetzen. Aber zum Beispiel,
einer der Vorträge handelt von Zukunft mit oder ohne Nazis und dem solidarischen Preppen.
Einer der Vorträge handelt, Rechtsrat gegen Rechte im Rechtsstaat,
also um juristischen Schutz gegen Rechts, also sowas wie gegen Rechtsschutz könnte man fast sagen.
Dann eine Zukunft ohne digitale Monopole, Tech-Pro-Milliardäre und ihre kapitalistische Kackscheiße,
darüber berichtet, eine ehemaliges Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestags so so und
dann gibt es einen Vortrag Freitag ich hab nichts gedacht Freitag 16.30 Uhr eine Zukunft nach Ibiza.
Also keine Ahnung, wer da in Frage kommen könnte die schon mal hier bei uns
im Programm gewesen ist.
Oder zum Beispiel eine antifaschistische Kritik an Astrologie und Esoterik.
Oh. Da habe ich jetzt auch überhaupt keinen Namen im Kopf.
Dann, da es wird etwas schwieriger vielleicht, da geht es um Schutzehen.
Leute heiraten, damit sie stattfüllen.
Und am Ende muss geklärt werden die Frage, was ist Zukunft?
Das wird glaube ich auch sehr lustig. Ich glaube, du kannst dir auch sehr gut vorstellen,
wer dieses Thema behandelt, auch bei Vorträgen an der Grenze zwischen Physik,
Philosophie und Bewusstseinserweiterung.
Die ganz großen Dinger, die ganz großen Fragen der Welt.
Das wird als, da gibt es schöne Themen am Freitag beim,
Haber, Zukunft Haber, Future Haber, Haber Future, wie auch immer das heißt.
Okay. Alright, das hat er jetzt ausreichend gepreppt und dann können wir euch
hier in die Woche entlassen.
Könnt ihr von Wien direkt morgens noch versuchen.
Ein Ticket of the Fusion zu ersteigern. Na toll.
Los, wir sagen jetzt tschüss. Bis bald.
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao. Bis zum nächsten Mal.